.
Ui, nein.
Boah, Schatz.
Ah, wie kommt die von hier weg?
Ich habe Angst. Geh weg, Schlange!
Bringst du mir mein Handy, please.
Schnell!
- Ja, ja.
Es ist ja nur eine kleine.
Meine Güte.
- Es ist eine kleine.
Da muss die Mutter in der Nähe sein.
- Nein.
An der Costa Blanca
wollen Corinne und Ralf Waldburger
ein Hotel für Hunde bauen.
Doch die Nachbarn
wehrten sich gegen die Pläne
und sammelten Unterschriften.
Es ist ein seltsames Gefühl.
Kaum angekommen,
sind die Nachbarn schon gegen dich.
In Cuxhaven begann Familie Caboussat,
ihren Wasserturm zu räumen.
Als zweites Standbein planten sie,
einen Oldtimer
in ein Kaffeemobil umzubauen.
Hier kommt die Kaffeemaschine hin
und da ein Möbelstück.
Und in Ruanda steckten die Schommers
mitten im Umbau fürs Fitnessstudio.
Ich freue mich, wenn es fertig ist.
Jetzt weiss ich nicht,
wohin ich schaue.
Als weitere Einnahmequelle
pflanzten sie Zitronengras an.
Es wäre nicht gut, wenn wir das
in den Sand setzen würden.
# Uf u dervo.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Vom neuen Zuhause
bis an die Stadtgrenze
der ruandischen Hauptstadt Kigali
sind es für Auswanderer
Marco Schommer 40 Min.
Alle paar Wochen kommt er hierher,
um auf seinem Zitronengrasfeld
nach dem Rechten zu sehen.
So.
Muraho, Chantal.
Sorry I'm late.
Marco ist mit Chantal verabredet.
Sie koordiniert
die Arbeiten auf dem Feld.
We go in between the lines.
- Yes.
(Englisch)
Auf den 3,5 ha Land wuchsen bisher
Bohnen, mit mässigem Ertrag.
Vor ein paar Wochen
startete Marco einen neuen Versuch
mit Zitronengrassetzlingen.
Ich war am Boden zerstört,
als ich sie sah,
und dachte: "Nein!"
Die Hälfte war kaputt.
Es sind 105'000 Setzlinge,
die gesetzt wurden.
Da steckt einiges an Geld drin.
Aber, und das sieht man gut:
Es kommt.
Es sind 30 Rp. pro Pflänzchen.
Wo hatten wir das?
Hier ist es feucht.
Here it is wet.
Yes.
Aus dem Zitronengras
wollen die Schommers später
Duftöl herstellen lassen.
Doch zuerst müssen die jungen
Pflanzen mit Humus gedüngt werden.
Nicht etwa mit Maschinen,
sondern Pflanze für Pflanze von Hand.
So.
Mzungu.
Gut 30'000 Fr.
hat Marco in das Feld investiert.
Dianne war etwas skeptisch.
Sie meinte, es sei etwas früh,
wir hätten es später machen sollen,
weil wir natürlich
relativ viel investieren mussten.
Andererseits haben wir nun erstens
die Erfahrung, wie man es macht.
Zweitens kommt während des Jahres
bereits etwas rein,
wenn das Gras gewachsen ist.
Okay, so.
Auf Marcos Feld arbeiten v.a.
Frauen aus den umliegenden Dörfern.
* Sie sprechen Kinyarwanda. *
* Marco versucht nachzusprechen. *
Marco muss noch
einiges mehr investieren,
bis er
die erste Ernte einfahren kann.
* Heitere Musik *
Die Idylle am Wattenmeer
könnte fast ein wenig
darüber hinwegtäuschen,
dass in Cuxhaven
so manches anders läuft,
als es sich die Auswanderer
aus dem Emmental erhofften.
Ein Jahr leben Mirabelle Caboussat
und ihre Familie
mittlerweile an der Nordsee.
* Schiffshorn *
Das ist eine der schöneren
Aussichten, die man hier haben kann.
Ich habe einen super Arbeitsplatz.
Die 51-Jährige
hat einen Minijob angenommen.
Ein paar Stunden pro Woche
arbeitet sie als Servicekraft
in einem Restaurant
an der Elbmündung.
Wo kommen die hin?
Die nimmst du mit, okay.
Ihr Traum
vom eigenen Café im Wasserturm
liegt nach wie vor in weiter Ferne.
Mirabelle macht das Beste daraus.
Durch den Job
kann sie Gastronomieerfahrung sammeln
und gleichzeitig
450 Euro im Monat dazuverdienen.
Alles, was reinkommt, ist gut.
Alain hat nach wie vor
seine Messen in der Schweiz.
Daher haben wir
ein regelmässiges Einkommen.
Das brauchen wir,
sonst hätten wir bald etwas Panik.
Aber so geht es.
Aber ...
Je länger es dauert, desto mehr Geld
verlieren wir, das ist so.
Da können wir noch lange
drum herumreden.
Mirabelle kellnert hier nun
seit ein paar Wochen.
Hallo.
Ich hab eine Laktoseintoleranz.
Was ist in dieser Sauce drin?
Ich kann nachfragen,
was da genau drin ist.
Es sollte aber gehen.
Ist die Orangensauce laktosefrei?
Nein.
(Frau)
Gib einfach Zitrone anstatt Sauce.
Zitrone?
- Ja.- Okay, mach ich.
Getränke?
- Ein kleines Wasser.
Mit oder ohne Kohlensäure?
- Mit.
Sie sprechen manchmal
etwas zu schnell,
und ich kann zu wenig gut Deutsch,
habe ich das Gefühl.
Kommt dazu, dass ich Bernerin bin
und deshalb etwas zu langsam.
Manchmal verstehen sie mich auch
nicht, z.B. bei der Kaffeesahne.
Jetzt weiss ich es, es heisst
nicht Crèmli, sondern Kaffeesahne.
Wenn Berndeutsch
auf Hochdeutsch trifft,
ist der Schweizer
vielleicht ein bisschen langsamer.
Beim Umbau des Wasserturms aber
geht es Familie Caboussat
nicht schnell genug.
In dem 120 Jahre alten Gebäude
wollen sie ein Café eröffnen,
ein Bed and Breakfast betreiben
und dereinst selber wohnen.
Doch es geht einfach nicht vorwärts
mit der Planung der Architekten.
In Bern ist Ehemann Alain
auf der Suche nach einer Lösung.
Für das Projekt will er
einen Ansprechpartner anstatt viele.
Und Schweizer Zuverlässigkeit.
Wir haben uns
für Schweizer Ingenieure
und ausführende Betriebe entschieden
beim Umbau des Turms.
Ich habe nun
meinen ehemaligen Chef gefragt,
ob er es anschauen
und übernehmen möchte -
für Sanitäranlagen,
die Heizung und die Lüftung.
Wir führten Gespräche,
und ihm gefiel die Idee.
Jetzt schauen wir,
was wir machen können.
Bauen ist Alain nicht fremd.
Bevor er
Betriebswirtschaft studierte,
arbeitete er über zehn Jahre
als Sanitärinstallateur.
Hallo, Ruedi, geht's gut?
- Alles klar, merci. Bei dir?
Tipptopp, viel zu tun.
Das hast du aber schön gemacht,
wunderbar vorbereitet.
Ich bin nicht
auf dem neuesten Stand.
Für mich ist es wichtig, etwa
auf deinen Wissenstand zu kommen.
Im ersten UG
haben wir die Wassereintritte.
Das Abwasser ist im zweiten UG,
gleich über der Decke.
Diese zwei Geschosse
werden zum Café.
Fünftes und sechstes Geschoss
beide Café?
Ja, genau.
Dann müssen wir ein technisches
Geschoss zwischenschalten,
z.B. eine Druckerhöhungsanlage
unten,
und eine Feinverteilung
für oben.
Alain hofft, dass er den Wasserturm
mit Schweizer Know-how
endlich voranbringen kann.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Im Frühjahr 2020 passiert das,
womit niemand gerechnet hat.
(Spanisch)
Zusammen mit Italien ist Spanien
trauriger Spitzenreiter
in Bezug auf Corona.
Die Zahl der Fälle
steigt drastisch an.
(Mann) Die Hoffnung war gross,
die Massnahmen rigoros.
Seit Mitte März legt eine landes-
weite Ausgangssperre Spanien lahm.
Verwaiste Strände und leere Gassen,
acht Wochen lang.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge,
Glockenschläge *
Auch Deutschland
schliesst die Grenzen
und fährt
das öffentliche Leben herunter.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Ruanda verhängt eine Ausgangssperre,
schliesst Schulen und Universitäten
und macht Masken
im öffentlichen Leben zur Pflicht.
Nichts geht mehr.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Ich weiss nicht, ob Ethiopian
Airlines jetzt wieder fliegen.
Momentan holen sie immer noch
Leute zurück nach Ruanda.
Und gewisse Leute,
die in ihr Heimatland zurück wollen.
Aber keine Reisende oder Touristen.
Es gibt doch diesen Song,
kennst du den?
Welchen?
- "Bälpmoos".
# Spick mi furt vo hie.
* Er lacht. *
Das ist Patent Ochsner.
Es ist Mitte Mai.
Nach ursprünglichem Plan stünden
Corinne Waldburger und ihr Mann Ralf
jetzt kurz vor der Eröffnung
ihrer Hundepension.
Weil die Baubewilligung fehlte,
nutzten sie die ersten Wochen nach
der Ankunft, um sich einzurichten.
Dann kam der Lockdown.
Schauen wir mal,
ob es etwas Neues gibt.
Hier steht jetzt:
"Update:
weitgehende Maskenpflicht in Spanien
tritt am Donnerstagmorgen in Kraft."
"Keine Tragepflicht in der Natur,
am Strand oder beim Spaziergang,
wenn der Mindestabstand
gewährleistet ist."
Bei uns ist man quasi
auf einer Insel,
es ist alles friedlich.
Und dann geht man raus
in die böse Welt.
Für unser Projekt ...
... ist es
natürlich gerade etwas hinderlich.
Am Anfang harzte es schon etwas
mit den Behörden.
Jetzt läuft natürlich gar nichts
mehr, weil alles geschlossen ist.
Wir hoffen ...
dass es schnell vorübergeht,
damit wir einen Schritt
vorwärts machen können
und wir unsere Bewilligung erhalten.
Es kommt schon, wir müssen
einfach etwas Geduld haben.- Ja.
Für den Moment bleibt den Waldburgers
nicht viel mehr als Warten.
Es ist angenehm.
- Ja? Ist es nicht kalt?
Juhu!
* Sie lacht. *
* Hupen *
In Ruandas Hauptstadt Kigali
gibt es erste Lockerungen
der Massnahmen gegen die Ausbreitung
des Coronavirus.
Nach sechs Wochen zu Hause fahren
die Schommers zum ersten Mal wieder
in ihr zukünftiges Fitnessstudio.
Es ist ein Durcheinander.
Wir dachten, dass wir bis jetzt
ein Einkommen haben würden.
Aber es schloss ja sofort alles,
und deshalb brachte es
unsere Pläne durcheinander.
Hier sind wir.
Anstatt Sportkurse
in ihrem neuen Studio zu geben,
muss sich Dianne
nach wie vor um den Umbau kümmern.
Die Räumlichkeiten für den
Fitnessklub sind noch nicht fertig.
Aha.
Langsam sieht man
die Grösse des Saals.
Die Decke
sieht jetzt auch viel besser aus.
Ich glaube,
das gibt eine gute Sache.
Jetzt ist die Farbe dran, und danach
muss der Boden gemacht werden.
Genau.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Vermieter Hamlet
ist für den Umbau zuständig.
Seine Arbeiter haben bereits
einen neuen Zugang zum Studio gebaut
und sanitäre Anlagen installiert.
Ganz nach den Wünschen der Schommers.
Und die Dusche?
* Sie sprechen Kinyarwanda. *
Ah, das ist die Herrentoilette
mit einem Ding. Das ist okay.
Hier ist die Dusche drin,
das ist jetzt auch besser.
Wir haben jetzt WC und Duschen,
haben aber vergessen,
dass man sich ja auch umziehen muss.
Es ist etwas blöd, weil er
die Arbeiten nun schon gemacht hat.
Dieser Gang hier existierte nicht,
den hat er komplett rausgeschlagen.
Aber andernfalls hätte er es
gleich berücksichtigen können,
jetzt ist es
auf gut deutsch scheisse.
(Französisch)
Garderobe?
- Oui, la garderobe.
Die Schommers wollen
nicht noch mehr Zeit verlieren.
Ihr Studio soll fertig sein,
wenn der Betrieb von Fitnessklubs
wieder erlaubt ist.
Es gibt wenige Fitessstudios,
und relativ viele Leute wohnen hier,
auch viele Reiche.
Die Idee ist,
dass wir uns zwischen
dem besten Fitnesscenter, Waka -
dessen Standard höher ist als das,
was wir anstreben -,
und den Massenfitnesscentern
positionieren.
Da glauben wir,
dass es einen Markt gibt.
Okay, what else do we need?
Das ist das Schild? Wow!
Wann kommt er mit dem Schild?
- Er hätte schon kommen sollen.
Aber du weisst ja: Afrikaner.
Es gibt schon gegnügend Gründe,
dass alles länger dauert.
Und jetzt kommt noch das Virus hinzu.
* Leises Hämmern *
Eigentlich
sieht alles so aus wie immer.
Aber bei Familie Caboussat
in Cuxhaven
sind die Auswirkungen
der Corona-Krise ebenfalls spürbar.
Sehr lecker.
Ist morgen schulfrei?
- Schulfrei? Homeoffice.
Homeoffice?
Was machst du im Homeoffice?
Wir bekommen dann per Internet ...
- ... Aufgaben?
Ja. Ich weiss nicht mehr genau wo.
Da muss ich nochmals nachfragen.
Den Job im Restaurant
muss Mirabelle derzeit aussetzen.
Und beim Wasserturm läuft
für den Moment auch nichts mehr.
Wir wollten ursprünglich
im April eröffnen.
Unser Ziel war 1. April 2020.
2020 hätten wir - rein theoretisch -
den Wasserturm eröffnen wollen.
Dann wären wir wirklich
in eine Krise geschlittert.
Dann hätten wir gleich wieder
schliessen können.
Die Caboussats haben beim Wasserturm
für einmal Glück im Unglück.
Das Schicksal meinte es auch anderswo
gut mit den Emmentalern.
Schon lange vor dem Lockdown
suchten sie nach Möglichkeiten
für ein weiteres Standbein.
Ihre Idee: eine mobile Kaffeebar.
Durch einen glücklichen Zufall
wurde die Idee mittlerweile Realität.
Das ist es, ja. Cafélino.
Alain und ich waren
auf einer Velotour
und kamen an einem Kaffeemobil vor-
bei, das Tag der offenen Tür hatte,
eine Art Fest.
Wir dachten: "Wenn es Kaffee gibt,
dann gehen wir hin."
Wir gingen hin und dann
sah Alain das Plakat, auf dem stand:
"Nachfolger gesucht".
Dann sagte Alain:
"Schau, der sucht einen Nachfolger."
Wir kamen ins Gespräch,
und er meinte: "Ja, doch ..."
Es war also
eine recht schnelle Entscheidung.
Eigentlich wollten sie ja ihren
Citroën HY als Kaffeemobil einsetzen.
Doch der Umbau des alten franzö-
sischen Lieferwagens ist schwierig
und braucht noch mehr Zeit.
* Brummen *
Ha! Massarbeit.
Mit dem Cafélino
konnten sie sofort loslegen.
Immer wieder
nach Lösungen suchen -
das machen Alain und ich gemeinsam.
Dann funktioniert es auch so.
So können wir uns
immer wieder aufraffen,
oder nicht mal aufraffen,
sondern einfach neue Wege suchen ...
... um zuerst Lösungen zu suchen
und dann zu finden,
damit es immer weitergeht.
Super, dass du die Milch bringst.
Das ist ideal.
Sehr gut. Stell sie gleich hierhin.
Ich muss hier kurz öffnen.
Vorsicht, dass nichts runterfällt.
- Da passiert gar nichts.
Für den Markt am nächsten Morgen
ist alles bereit.
Ready to go.
1'800 km weiter südlich.
Bei den Waldburgers
gibt es immer noch keine News
bezüglich der Baubewilligung
für das Hundehotel.
Unser Anwalt fragt jeweils nach,
wie weit sie sind.
Er sagte, er frage jeden Tag nach,
wobei das etwas unrealistisch ist.
Ja ... Aber wir hören nichts von
ihm, deshalb haken wir jeweils nach.
So, mal schauen, wie lange es geht,
bis wir eine Antwort erhalten.
Es kommt wieder eine Lieferung,
Schatz.
Schon wieder?
Was ist denn das?
Ah, der Kühlschrank.
Ein Gefrierschrank!
Ist hier gut?
- Ja. Muy bien.
Okay.
- Okay. Muchas gracias, adiós.
Ich bringe
den Lieferschein nach drinnen.
Vielleicht muss du schnell ... Nein,
es geht schon. Nicht so schwer.
Wir stellten uns darauf ein,
dass wir uns hier im Haus ...
... so einrichten,
dass wir fürs Haus nichts mehr
machen müssen, wenn der Bau losgeht.
Damit wir uns wirklich
dem Bau widmen können.
Ui, nein.
Boah, Schatz.
Ah, wie kommt die von hier weg?
Ich habe Angst. Geh weg, Schlange!
Bringst du mir mein Handy, please.
Schnell!
- Ja, ja.
Es ist ja nur eine kleine.
Meine Güte.
- Es ist eine kleine.
Da muss die Mutter in der Nähe sein.
- Nein.
Wahrscheinlich hat sie sich verirrt.
Zeig mal.
Geh bitte nicht zu nahe hin.
Ja, ja.
Es gibt Giftschlangen hier.
Wir haben
ein Buch von meinen Eltern,
in dem alle Tiere drin sind, die es
hier an der Costa Blanca gibt.
Es gibt hier Giftschlangen.
Woah! Oh mein Gott.
Oh nein.
- Schau mal.
Schau, wie sie den Kopf hebt.
Wir müssen schauen,
dass sie nicht ins Poolhaus geht.
Sie will vielleicht duschen.
- Ist sie in die Dusche rein?
Ja. Komm, wir lassen sie. Sie
kann hier ja nirgends rein, oder?
Nein, sie kann hier
nicht ins Poolhaus rein.
Wir lassen sie, oder?
Sie wird dann schon wieder gehen.
Das Problem ist,
dass sie hier nirgends ...
Ich weiss nicht,
wie sie hierhin kam.
Von hier kommt sie
nicht wirklich weg.
Was soll ich tun?
Die Grillzange holen?
* Sie lacht. *
Ich weiss nicht, ob die giftig ist.
Aber sie kann mich ja nicht beissen.
Ich versuch's mal.
Ich hole die Grillzange.
Zieh eine Sonnenbrille an, damit sie
dir kein Gift in die Augen spritzt.
Aber pass auf, Schätzchen. Wenn du
Angst hast, tust du es besser nicht.
Nein, nein.
Wo gehst du denn hin?
Bringst du sie hier rüber?- Ja.
Okay. Igitt.
Die faucht auch noch.
Sicher? Hast du sie?
Oh mein Gott.
Einfach nicht ... Ui, nein.
Ich muss etwas wegstehen.
Nicht, dass sie zurück schnellt,
wenn du ...
So, weg.
- Danke, mein Held.
Das ist super, Schatz.
Das hätte ich mich niemals getraut.
* Leises Hämmern *
Zumba-Trainerin Dianne hat in Ruanda
einen Termin beim Schreiner.
Das ist der Step fürs Aerobic.
Wir haben 30 Stück bestellt.
Sie sind noch dran,
es ist noch nicht fertig.
Das hier gefällt mir z.B. nicht,
hier hat es einen Spalt.
* Er spricht Kinyarwanda. *
Er hat gesagt,
dass sie das korrigieren.
Ich hoffe, dass es gut kommt.
Auch ein Regal für die Wertsachen
der Kunden sowie die Rezeption
lässt Dianne hier anfertigen.
Alles zusammen kostet die Schommers
rund 1 Mio. Ruanda Franc -
umgerechnet 900 Fr.
So. Heieiea.
- Heieia.
Der Boden fehlt immer noch.
Wo ist dein Auto?
Dort hinten. Soll ich dir helfen?
* Er lacht. *
Die Schuhe sind nicht ...
Nein, die sind nicht mehr schön.
Okay.
Nächster Stopp: ein Einkaufscenter.
* Hupen *
Jetzt muss ich zuerst
meine Schuhe entstauben.
Die Schommers brauchen noch
den passenden Bodenbelag
für ihr Fitnessstudio.
Oh.
- Steck es nicht in die Tasche.
* Hupen, heitere Musik *
* Piepen *
How much? Okay.
Hey Tity, how are you?
Tity ist der Cheftrainer
in ihrem zukünftigen Fitnessstudio.
Zu dritt suchen sie einen Belag,
der strapazierfähig ist,
aber nicht viel kostet.
Diese
typisch chinesischen Lampen ...
Man kommt sich fast vor
wie in China.
Tity schlägt vor,
Kunststofffliesen zu nehmen.
Sind die nicht rutschig?
Nein, das hat etwas, das bremst.
Wenn man das auf den Boden legt ...
Leg es mal auf den Boden.
Sports shoes ...
You have sports shoes on.
This is ... heikel. Oder nicht?
- Doch.
(Englisch)
Was denkst du? Schwarz?
Schwarz ist halt ... schöner.
Es sieht besser aus.
Haben sie noch davon?
Das wird teuer.
Viermal 400 mal 2'800,
4,5 Mio.
Was?
- Ja.
Die Fliesen kosten rund 4'000 Fr.
Ich weiss nicht ...
Okay. That's for sure.
Für das Praktische
bin ich zuständig.
Und er kümmert sich
um den Papierkram.
So haben wir es uns aufgeteilt.
Er kann besser kalkulieren als ich.
Er spielt also eine grosse Rolle.
Ohne ihn ... Ich weiss nicht.
Ja ... Alleine traue ich mich nicht,
so was Grosses zu machen.
Ich bin froh,
dass wir es zusammen machen.
Mich musst du nicht bitten,
eine solche Lampe anzuschrauben.
Aber schreiben,
wie gross sie sein soll ...
Das kann ich, ja.
Alright, thank you.
2 % sind nicht gerade viel.
Ein knausriger Rabatt,
aber immerhin können die Schommers
eine weitere Sache
auf ihrer Pendenzenliste abhaken.
* Möwenrufe *
* Der Motor springt an. *
Für Mirabelle beginnt kurz nach
6 Uhr in der Früh die Arbeit.
Anstatt ins eigene Café im Wasserturm
geht es
mit dem Kaffeemobil zum Wochenmarkt.
Zum ersten Mal seit Corona.
Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Geht's dir gut?
- Ja, Morgen, Mirabelle.
Schön, wieder auf dem Markt zu sein.
Wie geht es dir so?
- Ich freue mich, wieder anzufangen.
Ich mich auch. So kann ich meinen
Cappuccino gleich entgegennehmen.
Genau! Ich freu mich.
- Ich freu mich auch jetzt schon.
Bis nachher, tschüss.
Die Caboussats
gehören auf dem Markt bereits dazu.
Der Vorbesitzer des Wagens
hat die Emmentaler
gut in das Geschäft eingeführt.
Ich stecke es gleich ein.
Wir machen es eigentlich gemeinsam.
Mit Corona sind es am Mittwoch
aber nur wenige Leute,
dann übernimmt eine Person,
sonst ergibt es keinen Sinn.
Beim Aufstellen und Zusammenräumen
helfe ich aber.
Bis zum Lockdown kamen die Caboussats
zweimal pro Woche
mit ihrem Cafélino hierher.
Heute hat ihnen der Marktleiter
einen neuen Standplatz zugewiesen.
Das ist nicht gut, wieso ziehst du?
Jetzt ... hör doch auf zu ziehen.
Das bringt doch nichts.
Schatz, du kannst es nicht näher
ziehen, das Kabel wird nicht länger.
Reicht es nicht? Dann müssen wir
den Wagen etwas verschieben.
Das ist jetzt etwas doof.
Nein, es geht nicht.
Unter den Autos durch?
Nein, du kannst nicht unter
dem grossen Lastwagen hindurch.
Meinst du, das ist ...
Ich fahre noch
ein paar Zentimeter nach vorne.
Ah, super. Sehr gut.
Problem gelöst.
Die Kunden können kommen.
Jetzt machen wir
die offizielle Eröffnung.
So, voilà.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ralf ist ein Macher. Rumsitzen und
Däumchen drehen ist nicht sein Ding.
Bevor er auswanderte,
war der 50-Jährige Chef über das
Ersatzteillager in einem Autohaus.
Ah, hier.
Ich dachte, ich setze mich
auf den Schlitten und warte.
Bis es schneit?
Lass uns das mal messen.
Wie viel Abstand
müssen wir genau haben?
Steht das im Akustikplan? Nein.
Ich glaube, hier ist es. 18,36.
18,36.
Machen wir 19 m.
Ralf will die Zwangspause nutzen,
um das Hundehotel abzustecken.
Die beiden wollen sehen, wo genau das
Gebäude auf ihrem Gelände hin soll.
Die Position steht im Lärmgutachten,
das sie einhalten müssen.
Hier wären es schon 20 m.
Gut. Bleibst du da stehen, damit wir
den Pfahl einschlagen können?
Das Problem:
Die Nachbarn wollen nicht,
dass Ralf und Corinne
hier ein Hundehotel bauen.
Sie fürchten um ihre Ruhe.
Aber so -
wenn man so schaut,
habe ich nicht das Gefühl,
dass es
extrem nahe beim Nachbarn ist.
Wir halten den Abstand ein.
Das Gebäude zeigt in diese Richtung.
Die Ausläufe zeigen hierhin.
- Und hier ist ja nichts.
Jegliche Kontaktaufnahme
schlug bisher fehl.
Einmal hielt Corinne die Nachbarin
auf der Strasse an,
ein anderes Mal hinterliessen wir
einen Brief am Tor.
Wir haben schon gehupt,
gemacht, getan - keine Antwort.
Jetzt haben wir nochmals
einen Brief aufgesetzt.
Darin haben wir ihnen unseren
Standpunkt ganz klar mitgeteilt.
Wir haben geschrieben,
dass wir uns bewusst sind,
dass es durch die Lärmemissionen
der Hunde etwas lauter wird,
dass wir aber auch hier wohnen
und darauf bedacht sind,
dass es nicht laut wird.
Das können wir ihm
nicht klarmachen.
Es ist schade.
Wenn es jetzt schon Probleme gibt,
gibt es sie auch in Zukunft.
Deshalb suchen wir das Gespräch.
Gib Bescheid, wenn wir 20 m haben.
Du musst etwas langsamer gehen.
Warte schnell.
19, un momento -
etwa hier.
Komm noch etwas näher.
Ja, ja, ungefähr 20 m.
Nicht ungefähr, sondern 20 m.
Aha, ganz genau?
- Ja, denn das gibt das Fundament.
Selbst wenn die Waldburgers
den Streit mit den Nachbarn
rasch lösen könnten, bauen
dürften sie trotzdem noch nicht.
Dazu fehlt ihnen die Bewilligung,
auf die sie schon
seit über sechs Monaten warten.
Wir haben
die Budgetaufstellung so gemacht,
dass wir sicher ein Jahr lang
keine Einnahmen haben.
Ich mache jeden Monat
eine Budgetplanung,
um zu schauen, wo wir stehen.
Denn wir hatten Ausgaben,
die nicht budgetiert waren.
Wir sind aber immer noch im Soll.
Ralf und Corinne versuchen,
positiv zu bleiben -
trotz Verzögerung
und feinseliger Nachbarn.
In Cuxhaven
hat Alain den Markt verlassen
und sich in sein Atelier in der Nähe
des Wasserturms zurückgezogen.
Bis der Turm fertig ist,
sind sie auf seinen Verdienst
als selbstständiger Messeleiter
angewiesen.
Von der Nordsee aus organisiert
der 49-Jährige eine Fachmesse,
die im Frühjahr 2021
in Zürich stattfinden soll.
Wenn die AQUA Suisse
nicht durchgeführt würde,
wäre das nicht so lustig für mich.
Aber ich bin zuversichtlich.
Es bringt nichts, darüber
nachzudenken, was wäre, wenn.
Als Selbstständiger
trägt man ein gewisses Risiko.
Aber ich sehe es gelassen.
Wenn nicht,
muss ich etwas anderes machen.
Irgendwie geht es schon weiter.
Keine einfache Situation,
denn über die Messe hinaus
hat Alain momentan
keine weiteren Aufträge.
Besser läuft es auf dem Markt,
wenn auch mit speziellen Auflagen.
Ich darf leider nicht.
- (Lachend) Nein.
Ist das das erste Mal wieder?
Ja.
- Wie schön!
Wir vermissen euch so.
Wir sind glücklich,
dass es hier wieder losgeht.
So, einmal hier.
Danke schön.
Anders als bisher darf Mirabelle den
Kaffee nur zum Mitnehmen ausgeben.
Das längere Gespräch fehlt.
Normalerweise hätten ich und Anke,
die vorhin hier war,
einen kleinen Schwatz gehalten.
Dieser Austausch
ist schön und wichtig.
Und der fehlt jetzt.
Dafür stecke ich jetzt
noch etwas mehr Herz rein.
Für Marktbeschicker sind es 2.50.
Die Schweizer Leckereien
und der Kaffee kommen an.
Mittlerweile haben Mirabelle
und Alain bereits viele Stammkunden.
Natürlich kommt das Gespräch
auch immer wieder auf den Wasserturm.
Was macht eigentlich
euer Projekt in Cuxhaven?
Das dauert noch ein bisschen. Bald
reichen wir die Baugenehmigung ein.
Aber - wie gesagt:
Ich verspreche nichts mehr.
Denn es kann immer
etwas dazwischenkommen,
oder es gibt neue Anforderungen.
Wenn ihr da seid, sind wir
mit die Ersten, die kommen.
Das freut uns.
Tschüss!
Habt ihr den Zettel bekommen?
Am Sonntag
sind wir in einer neuen Reihe.
Super.
- Tschüss.
Hallo, moin.
Der Zuspruch der Kunden
tut Caboussats sichtlich gut.
* Heitere Musik *
Marco
muss sich im neuen Leben in Ruanda
immer wieder
auf Unbekanntes einlassen.
In der Schweiz war der Maschinenbau-
ingenieur fest angestellt.
Als Direktor einer Uhrmacherschule
verdiente er genug
für sich und seine Frau Dianne.
In Kigali brauchen
die Schommers mehrere Standbeine,
um finanziell
über die Runden zu kommen.
How are you? Good?
You found it.
Schon vor der Auswanderung
hatte Marco Kontakte geknüpft
und sich nach Jobmöglichkeiten
in Ruanda umgehört.
Ich habe mich inzwischen
bei verschiedenen Firmen beworben.
Ich erhielt auch ein paar Absagen.
Manche Positionen
sind auch noch offen.
Auch um Mandate zu suchen, ist es -
mit dem momentanen Lockdown -
noch schwieriger geworden,
weil man niemanden treffen konnte.
Aber ja -
es gestaltet sich schwieriger,
als ich es mir anfangs
erhofft und gewünscht hätte.
Nun hat Marco
ein erstes Mandat erhalten,
nach sieben Monaten
in der neuen Heimat.
Im Auftrag einer Stiftung
soll Marco ein Konzept für
die ruandische Regierung erstellen.
Diese möchte
die duale Berufsausbildung
nach Schweizer Modell
in Ruanda einführen.
Für diese Aufgabe kann Marco
auf seine Erfahrung
in der Uhrmacherschule zurückgreifen.
Knapp 40 Arbeitstage
kann er dafür abrechnen.
Nicht viel,
aber zumindest ein Anfang.
Das Schild im Fitnessklub hängt.
Die Umkleidekabinen sind fertig.
Alles ist neu gestrichen.
Was noch fehlt, ist der Boden.
Einen Teil des Saals lassen die
Schommers mit Betonfarbe streichen.
Das ist günstiger
als die Kunststofffliesen.
Hello.
* Sie spricht Kinyarwanda. *
Es sieht gut aus.
Es kommt besser, als ich dachte.
(Englisch)
Das Fitnessstudio ist endlich
auf gutem Weg, Dianne ist zufrieden.
* Autotür fällt ins Schloss. *
Wir gehen zum Trust Resort,
das ist ein Hundehotel mit einem
riesigen Hundepool und -betreuung.
Da erkundigen wir uns und schauen,
wie es aussieht.
* Bellen. *
Die beiden erhoffen sich
Tipps aus erster Hand.
Die Besitzer der Anlage
sind ebenfalls Schweizer.
Hallo!
- Hallo zusammen.
Corona-Gruss, oder?
- Ja, genau.
Die Maske muss ich
auch noch anziehen.- Nein, nein.
Hallo, Aldo.
Aldo und Christa
eröffneten ihr Resort 2018.
Es gehört zu den grössten Spaniens.
Weisst du,
bei uns ist es so:
Der Verkäufer des Hauses wusste,
was wir planen.
Das Problem ist ...
Wir haben uns erkundigt,
und es hiess, es ginge.
Was wir erfahren haben:
Das Minimum sind 10'000 m2.
Das haben die Behörden
uns so mitgeteilt.
Die Gemeinde hat schon Ja gesagt.
Die Anlage hat 63'000 m2 -
zehnmal so viel
wie das Grundstück der Waldburgers,
auf dem sie
ihre Hundepension bauen wollen.
Das ist halt schon toll.
- Ja, mega.
Das ist hammermässig.
Hier ist es wie am Beach.
- Ja.
Die Leute
fühlen sich wie am Strand.
Ja, sie relaxen,
und die Hunde können baden.
Oh, schau mal.
Oh, Schätzchen.
Ich bin nicht jemand, der neidisch
ist auf Dinge, die andere haben.
Etwas in dieser Grösse
haben wir niemals geplant.
Wir machen Tagesausflüge mit den
Hunden, die bei uns beherbergt sind,
und kommen zum Schwimmen hierhin -
perfekt.
Genau.
- Ein Tagesausflug.
Sicher!
Die Bewilligungen für die Anlage
zu organisieren,
war auch
für Christa und Aldo nicht einfach.
Zweieinhalb Jahre
haben sie dafür gebraucht.
Obwohl wir
spanische Teilhaber haben,
die uns darauf aufmerksam machten,
was es alles braucht,
wussten auch wir nicht,
dass es so lange dauern würde.
Wenn man dann noch Nachbarn hat,
die Schwierigkeiten bereiten -
dann ist das natürlich schwierig
und wird vermutlich langwierig.
Die Waldburgers können nur hoffen,
dass Aldo sich täuscht.
In der nächsten Folge staut sich
bei Ralf immer mehr Ärger an.
Er ist frustriert, weil wir hier
sind und einfach noch nichts läuft.
Ausserdem geht der Streit
mit den Nachbarn in eine neue Runde.
Man schiesst via Medien gegen uns,
anstatt an einen Tisch
zu sitzen und zu reden.
Der Wasserturm in Cuxhaven
entpuppt sich als Fass ohne Boden.
Die Caboussats
wollen die Stadt mit ins Boot holen.
Sie treffen den Bürgermeister.
Wir sind froh, dass Sie da sind.
In Ruanda sucht Marco
einen Käufer für das Zitronengras.
Es zeigt sich, ob es sich
gelohnt hat, es anzupflanzen.
Und ihr Fitnessstudio
bereitet den Schommers erneut Sorgen.
Heute haben wir eine
nicht so gute Nachricht erhalten.
# U si stige i Flüger,
flüge mit de Vögu furt
# und chöme nümme hei.
# U sie löh hie aues zrugg
uf dr Suechi für nes nöis Dahei.
# Si göh hüt nu uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Désirée Häfeli - 2021